wir sind natürlich stolz und besonders
glücklich dass wir jetzt zum ersten mal
ab in deutschland und nach europa
ausliefern können und freuen uns freuen
uns dass das es abgeben jedes zwanzigste
losgeht
wie emotional aber ist das für sie
persönlich das ist jetzt auch in
deutschland losgehen kann
ich habe heute mit einem kollegen
gesprochen der sagte na ja das ist so
ein bisschen wie die mondlandung fast
also wie glücklich sind sie dass das
jetzt losgehen kann
wir sind gesund wir sind unendlich
glücklich wir haben wir haben ja
wirklich in den letzten wochen sehr sehr
intensiv mit der europäischen
regulierungsbehörden zusammen gearbeitet
da haben sehr sehr viele mitarbeiter die
nächte durchgearbeitet um die fragen zu
adressieren
um immer wieder mit der ehemaligen
kontakt zu sein weil wir uns diesen tag
herbeigesehnt haben auch heute morgen
gab es noch eine ganze reihe von fragen
als zehn minuten nach gab es kontakt mit
der eu zum glück hat es jetzt geklappt
so dass wir die letzte planung mit dem
die kinder ins haben sieben einhalten
können
wenn ich leute mischt aber vermutlich
erst am 27 noch mal wichtig freundin ist
denn es mit den ersten menschen aber die
ersten mädchen ihre impfstoffe bekommen
das haben sie gerade gesagt sie haben so
eng mit der eben auch zusammengearbeitet
haben sie also auch verständnis dafür
dass das ganze doch etwas länger
gedauert hat denn in anderen ländern
beispielsweise england und den usa wurde
ja schon geimpft experten haben gesagt
das hätte ich hier in deutschland oder
in europa auch leben kosten können dass
wir jetzt noch warten mussten
ja wir haben natürlich absolut
verständnis ist es ja ganz einfach so
das ist in verschiedenen ländern europas
nun mal an staaten konglomerat
unterschiedliche prozessoren gibt und
diese prozeduren müssen dann auch
entsprechend abgearbeitet werden
und ich kann nur bestätigen dass die
zusammenarbeit mit den kollegen von der
e mail exzellent gewesen ist da haben
auch die deutschen behörden mitgeholfen
geholfen dass wir da eine ganze reihe
von fragen auch gemeinsam beantworten
konnten
weil die deutschen kollegen die von der
form vom paul-ehrlich-institut aber
nimmt uns schon seit 4
zehn jahren zusammen so dass dadurch
auch der ganze prozess erleichtert und
nochmal beschleunigt werden konnte jetzt
kann man natürlich alle kaum noch
abwarten der 27 dezember ist die jetzt
im wahrsten sinne antwortete das ist
stichtag da wird die ersten spritzen
hier dann geben könnte es nicht
theoretisch jetzt schon viel früher
losgehen sogar morgen schon bei den
ältesten also das ist das ist sehr sehr
genug ist die quote haben heute leute
noch noch die noch die letzten tests
durchgeführt und das ganze hatte
normales prozedere dass jede freigegeben
arzneimittel stärker auf mach mal
getestet werden muss und das ist heute
erfolgt und dementsprechend farben gegen
lastwagen wenn das waren auch heute
abend das losfahren
sie müssen die die entsprechenden plätze
in den 27 ländern erreichen und es muss
sichergestellt werden dass die logistik
wirklich perfekt abläuft
deshalb bin ich glücklich dass es nicht
nur morgen losgeht sondern erst am 27
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren